since 1938 Superman has been a massive
part of pop culture and we all know his
story or do we I'm Walter Bernays yak
and this is top five over the Man of
Steel's nearly 80 year history he's
changed a lot many of his powers have
grown and diminished throughout the
decades but there are many concrete
things we know about Superman
that make up the character we all
recognize given the name kal-el at birth
he's the son of jor-el and Lara he's
from the planet Krypton which explodes
as he's jettisoned off his homeworld
supposedly being its last survivor he
lands in Smallville Kansas and is raised
by Jonathan and Martha Kent he develops
powers due to his dense molecular
structure and is powered by the Earth's
Yellow Sun he works at the Daily Planet
newspaper as Clark Kent while protecting
metropolis and the world as Superman
he's typically the moral standard in any
situation and is pretty humbled
considering he has all the powers of a
god he also has a thing for Lois Lane
plenty of stories over the years have
messed around with those tent poles
changing an aspect of his origin here
tweaking his personality there lots of
these little alterations changed the
character in interesting ways and create
fresh tales for him to be challenged by
some of those variations on Superman
makeup some of my personal favorite
comics and animated movies and episodes
so I thought I'd share them with you
today these are the top 5 best alternate
versions of Superman number 5 Soviet
Superman from Superman red Sun instead
of crashing in Kansas Superman's rocket
ship plummets down to earth in the
middle of a Ukrainian collective farm
and the 1950s Superman makes his public
debut as a pawn of the Soviet government
gone are the values of truth justice and
the American Way as they are replaced
with Superman being the champion of the
common worker who fights a never-ending
battle for Stalin socialism and the
international expansion of the Warsaw
Pact the premise of Superman being
raised in Soviet Russia may just sound
like a decent gimmick to give us a
unique story but red Sun is so much more
than that
this book isn't a simple good guys bad
guys deal it would have been easy to
make it that way and just have Superman
be the evil communist but writer Mark
Millar goes for something much
or nuanced this version of Superman has
a lot of inner conflict he truly
believes what he's doing is the right
thing however the circumstances
surrounding his reluctant ascent to
power see him compromised in ways that
become more and more terrifying the
longer he remains in that position this
is a long-term story over a period of
many years so in it we see Superman
change as the weight of running most of
the world starts to affect his once more
optimistic and innocent approach to
peace Lex Luthor in this story is the
perfect foil for Superman their rivalry
now extends from just metropolis to the
US versus Russia Lex makes Superman and
even more interesting character in this
book also we get some amazing sequences
that involved red Suns versions of
Batman Wonder Woman and Green Lantern
there are a lot of unexpected twists and
turns across all three parts of this
story and it might be the best one told
on this list its depiction of Superman
alone is worth checking it out
number four kal-el the Green Lantern of
space sector one zero zero three and
Superman last son of Earth Jonathan Kent
is a scientist who sends his infant son
Clark into space as a way of saving him
from a meteor that is about to level the
planet instead of staying in orbit and
returning to Earth after the most severe
damage has run its course
a wormhole appears and transports the
rocket ship to Krypton jor-el and Laura
discover the ship and the former decides
to raise the encased baby as his own son
and heir he is slowly eased into the
rougher atmosphere of Krypton and grows
to adulthood there when the adopted
kal-el discovers the ruins of a crashed
Green Lantern vessel he becomes the
Lantern assigned to Krypton's space
sector however kal has many questions
that have plagued his mind since he was
young
the main one being where did he come
from the idea of Superman as a Green
Lantern is another cool premise who
would want to see that but the aspect to
this story that intrigued me the most is
the fact that Superman is sent from
earth to Krypton writer steve gerber
takes his time in telling the backstory
of all the players and settings involved
before going off and following Kyle's
journey he's definitely an outcast as an
earthling and Krypton and in a very
different way from the reversal that
were used to he's effectively relatable
this just feels refreshing and works
surprisingly well after becoming a Green
Lantern kal-el starts to really push his
adoptive father on the issue of his true
origins this all leads to return to
Earth where the originally named Clark
Kent searches for answers I won't spoil
the rest of the story as I think it
should get more attention but this
version of Superman comes across very
different while holding the characters
true essence at his core there was a
sequel made a few years later called
Last Stand on Krypton but I don't think
it's all that great just stick the last
son on earth for a fun and engaging
alternate Superman experience number 3
superboy-prime
now this one is a bit confusing I'll try
to make it simple this version of Clark
Kent hails from Earth prime a world
meant to be similar to our own where
superheroes including Superman only
exist in comic books many things about
this character's background are
identical or very close to the
mainstream version he was transported
from Krypton to earth and raised there
by a couple with the last name Kent
while in his teens he had yet to develop
his powers when we first meet him in
DC's legendary event crisis on Infinite
Earths in this storyline his powers
manifest while the multiverse including
his earth is being destroyed years after
that event in 2006's Infinite Crisis he
returns as a crazed villain hell-bent on
recreating his earth and destroying
anyone in his way his fractured mind in
addition to his Superman powers make him
one of the most powerful villains in the
DCU there's a lot more to his story but
the main idea here is that this is a
young confused Superman whose earth was
destroyed and he has completely lost his
mind
superboy-prime is a great villain
because we can almost sympathize with
him he was pulled from an earth that was
wiped from existence while years of
isolation and prodding basically turned
him into a psychopath he is a big
villain in the main DCU which means he's
in a lot of stories all the way up to
very recently so I'll just give you a
few reading suggestions if you want some
examples of what he's all about you
could start at Infinite Crisis where
they explain the very complicated events
that happen in crisis on Infinite Earths
while reintroducing him as a villain
also take a look at Sinestro Corps war
in addition to being a fantastic Green
Lantern arc superboy-prime is a big
baddie in that one
has a few great fights number two
Superman son of Zod in Justice League
gods and monsters just as jor-el is
about to enter his DNA into a birthing
matrix that is to be sent off a dying
Krypton General Zod busts in and instead
adds his DNA to the sequence this mixes
with Loras as the spaceship containing
me now developing fetus travels to earth
years later in much different backstory
has now occurred still taking the name
Superman the son of Zod is in the
Justice League with alternate versions
of Batman and Wonder Woman they are much
more ruthless than we're used to and
while Superman does use his powers for
good he's a very different character
that constantly has an inner struggle
about doing the right thing versus his
own dominating desires without the house
of El being a part of him this Superman
is definitely not the character we all
know the drastic change in his parentage
creates a much more morally ambiguous
Man of Steel in addition to his
Kryptonian heritage being changed his
coming-of-age on earth is also massively
different while I suggest you all check
out Justice League gods and monsters if
you haven't you can really get the gist
of who this Superman is in a great short
that came out just before the film
called Bob in it Superman is tasked with
taking down Brainiac but this version of
Brainiac isn't just an emotionless
machine when I was a child I had to
learn how to control my powers you have
to control yours
concentrate I can't it's beautifully
tragic and I'd love to see more about
this version of Superman maybe one day
we'll get more
[Music]
and the number one best alternate
version of Superman is Clark Kent in
Superman secret identity inspired by the
original appearances of superboy-prime
the Clark Kent and secret identity does
bear some similarities to that version
of the character but he's taken in a
completely different direction
Clark Kent is a regular American boy who
was named after Superman's alter ego as
a joke by his family a family who also
just so happens to live in a small town
in Kansas as with superboy-prime
Superman and superheroes only exist in
the pages of comic books Clark
constantly has to deal with the obvious
comparisons to the fictional Superman
and is often picked on for it one night
out of seemingly nowhere
Clark develops superpowers very close to
that of the Man of Steel however this is
still very much a realistic world so no
super villain stepped forth to oppose
him and Clark decides to keep his power
secret while doing good as often as
possible we follow him through his life
as a writer and author while he
privately becomes the hero he was once
mocked for sharing a name with in my
opinion this is the most complete
character of any of the ones mentioned
here and he exists and probably my
favorite Superman comic it's just an
amazing simple story but it works
perfectly for what they went for a
character study throughout we see Clark
from high school to old age as
everything is presented from his
perspective as stated before this is an
exactly Superman since he's only a
comic-book character in this world this
Clark is not from Krypton
there's nothing really abnormal about
him until he mysteriously develops his
powers writer Kurt Busiek really knocked
it out of the park with this thoughtful
and authentic feeling life really it's a
portrait of someone's life in four
wonderful parts Clark has real concerns
and is living in a way we can all relate
to you with the added benefits and
stress of having Superman like powers I
love this characterization and story he
lives in it's a great book so look for
Superman's secret identity if you want
the ultimate alternate Superman I'd
suggest to you to check out all the
comics and animated projects I've
presented here for fun and different
takes on a character many of us have
loved our whole
for more content subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome Walter like many Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome Walter B and
follow me on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week for a
brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
you